Tối nay ngày 20 tháng 30, các bạn hãy nhìn phụ hành động đã thông tin bàn đầu về vụ việc xế ra tại thủ bục mút sau vàn thích,
hà chỉ phường kiến thường.
Theo đó, vào tối qua, trên mạng sở hội rất hiện đọn video ghi lại cảnh 1 năm sở điều khiến sẽ mấy hòn đà
vizz nừng có hình vì dùng tay đánh người điều khiến sẽ mấy mỏ sám tại nước sau vàn thích, hà chỉ phường kiến thường.
Này khi tiếp nhận thông tin, các bạn phường kiến thường đã như trong phòng phòng cuộc đưa ra,
đã nhìn được rất bị là anh đến nở tê, sinh năm 20, các bạn tìm tư chú phần nông viên,
hà nội, hiện anh tê đang đi thám thương tích và làm việc quay cơ quan công an để phối hồ cụ cấp thường tin.
Nguyễn có hình vì hình cũng anh tê là nở cơ tê, sinh năm 20, sinh năm tà mi một chú phần kiến thường.
Thời điểm sức định, các tê không có mặt tại địa phương, ra điểm chưa gió đi đâu.
Hình không ăn phương kiến thường đang tiếp tục thủ tập tại liệu,
chữa tập những người có lấy quan để xử liên nghiêm theo về địa của pháp lật.